Could be worse. Could just be in my ears
only.
[Arabic recitation]
Huh?
Abu Hafs. Correct. And what's his
nickname?
Correct.
And
What year did Umar ibn al-Khattab pass
away?
13?
20 23. So, 13 years after
the prophet's death.
Three
two companions.
So, we can
calculate exactly how old
how much older the prophet
is from Abu Bakr and
Because we said that
was how many years?
Two years and some months.
And Umar's was how many
years?
Mhm?
13 and some months.
Correct.
And all of them died at 63 years old.
So, that would place
Abu Bakr as being 2 years younger
than the prophet
was selling.
I mean
Umar
it was 13 years and change, meaning
after the prophet's death. 10 years and
change was the length of his life.
So, we have
Abu Bakr 2 years and change. Then we
have Umar for 10 years and change. We're
now at 23 after Asia.
Then we have who comes in.
And he had the longest, which was
roughly 13 years.
His life was. And then after him was Ali
ibn Abi Talib and his was how many
years?
Four years
and a bit.
Which places us just at the cusp of 30
years.
And that is the length of life
as the prophet
mentioned.
Why am I saying all of this?
Because
one of the
strategic placements
of
the narrators
biographies, shortened biographies, the
stories, some of the
some of the virtues, some of the merits,
some of the facts about the various
companions
and them
are often strategically placed by the
scholars
in their books, which explain
the the books of narration.
So, if we were in for instance to take a
detour and listen to some of the
some of the life and times of Umar ibn
al-Khattab and them.
This doesn't really have anything
directly to do with the chapter that
we're in, right? Which is the theme of
the chapter, which is the chapter.
But it's an opportunity for us to get to
know these various companions and
narrators of Hadith.
Now, we can take two methods here.
We can either
not really get into that and just
focus on the narrations,
or we can work that in
to the
reading
of
as we go through each companion that we
haven't mentioned before,
we
mention some of his biography
and life and times, some of his merits,
some of his life,
when he became Muslim, when he left
when he departed from this world, when
he passed away.
And when we pass by that companion
again, we can review those things that
we mentioned. Or we can
kind of ignore that, just get to know
the names alone, and focus more on the
narrations.
Which Which one do you
all feel you would prefer?
The second one?
Just overlook it?
Which one?
To mention?
Yeah?
How do you think so? Jamil?
Is-haq?
Yeah?
Sabir? So, all the Africans agree.
[Arabic recitation]
them.
Well, we have to We have to then We have
to try to
make sure that we
try to soak it up and focus on it.
Because in order for us to get a clear
picture
of narrations, get a a full image,
we have to have some kind of idea
as to when these men and women lived and
when they died,
and their interactions with the Prophet
Sallallahu alayhi wasallam.
One of the most disorienting things
is not having a sense of time.
Have you ever woken up having overslept,
or lost track of time, or even just not
been able to look at a watch,
or be able to check the time for
a bit?
You know that feeling that you get of
being completely disoriented,
having no idea how long time has gone
by, what point in time you are
physically at the moment?
This is one of the most important
elements of knowledge, and in being able
to put together this image in our mind's
eye
as to these men, when they lived, when
they died, when they came and left the
biography of the Prophet Sallallahu
alayhi wasallam.
So,
their time of Islam,
their time of death, or their
date of death, etc. This is
paramount. So, let's give it a shot.
Let's see if we can
take some
get ourselves familiar with the
companions radiyallahu anhu,
and let's see if we can have some of
this information stick. So, if I mention
100% of details, or let's say
if you can remember at least 30 or 40%
of the details that I mention,
then that is actually a lot of detail.
And the most important
is
when they accepted Islam,
when they passed away,
and
you know, any main merits that they have
in their
in their lives.
So, we can start with
Mu'adh ibn Jabal radiyallahu anhu,
because that's the narration that we're
at now.
There's a narration in Musnad al-Imam
Ahmad.
The Prophet Sallallahu alayhi wasallam
said,
[Arabic recitation]
Mu'adh ibn Jabal."
He said Sallallahu alayhi wasallam, "The
most knowledgeable
man
of my ummah
with respect to halal and haram, lawful
and unlawful,
is Mu'adh
ibn Jabal radiyallahu anhu."
This is an incredible
an incredible
virtue, merit, and very significant.
And this merit of Mu'adh
it
is one of the reasons why
he had the appointments that he had by
the Prophet Sallallahu alayhi wasallam.
Mu'adh is considered to be one of the
representatives
of the Prophet Muhammad Sallallahu
alayhi wasallam
in that he was sent
to a number of people to call them to
Islam, entire tribes.
And he was sent as well to Yemen
to represent the Prophet Sallallahu
Alaihi Wasallam in judgment,
to invite and call the people of that
area to Islam,
to act as a judge,
and to
gather the zakat
and the alms from the people of Yemen
as
as commanded by Allah Subhana Wa Ta'ala.
Muadh ibn Jabal is a very interesting
young man, and I say young man because
many of us, if not most of us here right
now, are older than Muadh was when he
passed away.
Radiyallahu Anhu.
He passed away as a very young man,
and he passed away in the year 18 after
Hijrah.
And this is kind of
very, very curious because usually a
person
cannot
gather that kind of knowledge
or embody that kind of knowledge
without having spent a lifetime
studying and a lifetime practicing.
And there were others amongst the
companions, Radiyallahu Anhum,
who had spent more time with the Prophet
Sallallahu Alaihi Wasallam, who had been
Muslim longer, far longer than Muadh ibn
Jabal, Radiyallahu Anhum.
However, Muadh ibn Jabal,
he
was the most knowledgeable
of all of the companions with respect to
al-halal wal-haram.
Now, you might say, "More knowledgeable
than Abu Bakr?
More knowledgeable than Umar?" Naam.
That is the
meaning of the narration.
Listen to this narration,
which was collected by Imam Ahmad, it's
an authentic narration. The Prophet
Sallallahu Alaihi Wasallam said,
"Ashaddu
ummati rahmatan bi ummati Abu Bakr.
[Arabic recitation]
fi amrillah Umar.
a'lamu ummati bil-halal wal-haram
Muadh ibn Jabal.
[Arabic recitation]
Radiyallahu Anhu."
He said, Sallallahu Alaihi Wasallam,
that
the most merciful
man
amongst my nation,
of my nation, is Abu Bakr.
And the most
strict
of them
in the command and
boundaries of Allah is Umar.
And the truest of them in modesty
is Uthman.
And he goes on to say, "And the most
knowledgeable of my ummah
in halal and haram is Muadh ibn Jabal."
The apparent aspect of this narration,
were to take this narration at face
value,
Muadh ibn Jabal is more knowledgeable
with respect to lawful and unlawful than
any other companion of the Prophet
Sallallahu Alaihi Wasallam.
And that is the correct understanding.
Now, when we say that
the Prophet Sallallahu Alaihi Wasallam,
and this is an important point when we
get into the topic of the merits of the
prophets, the merits of the companions,
etc.
There is something which is called
al-
tafdil al-mutlaq,
right?
Or mutlaq at-tafdil,
[Arabic recitation]
When it comes to merits,
there are two types the scholars
mentioned.
The first type is general merit.
The second type is specific merit. What
does that mean?
I want you to imagine with me
the various prophets and messengers in
the Quran.
Allah Subhana Wa Ta'ala tells us
that he has
given virtue to some prophets over
others, correct?
And that some of the messengers, some of
the prophets are more virtuous than
others.
Who is the most virtuous
prophet and messenger of all the
prophets and messengers?
Huh?
[Arabic recitation]
Our prophet Muhammad sallallahu alaihi
wasallam,
this is called general virtue.
He is generally more virtuous than every
other prophet.
However, if we were to say specifically
in specific merits,
then there are other prophets that excel
even those who are a rank above them in
general merit.
So, for instance, when I when I ask you,
who is the most
virtuous prophet and messenger
with respect to specifically patience?
Not all general
aspects,
just in this one aspect, patience. Who
comes to my mind?
Ayyub alaihi wasallam.
Now,
if we were to say
who
comes to mind
with respect to virtues in the length,
the longevity
of his dawah, the time that he called
his people to Islam?
Nuh alaihi wasallam, correct? If we were
to say
who is the most virtuous of prophets
specifically speaking about appearance,
his physical appearance?
Huh?
Yusuf alaihi wasallam.
If we were to say who is most virtuous
amongst the prophets
with respect to revelation,
the way that he receives revelation, who
would that be?
Musa alaihi wasallam.
Why? Because he
speaks, he is kalimullah subhanahu wa
ta'ala, right?
If we were to
ask who is the
most virtuous
of prophets and messengers
with respect to miracles that are
mentioned in the Quran, specifically
miracles in their youth, who would we
say?
Isa alaihi wasallam. He spoke when he
was an infant, right? This is an
incredible miracle.
But these things, even though some of
them, or for instance, if I say who is
the most excellent of the prophets in
worship, specific worship, salah and
fasting,
who would it be?
Dawud alaihi wasallam.
The prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
said
that the most best, most beloved fasting
to Allah is the fasting of Dawud,
correct? The most beloved prayer to
Allah in qiyam is the qiyam of Dawud
alaihi wasallam.
So,
just because Dawud
happened to fast more than Muhammad
sallallahu alaihi wasallam in that one
aspect and that specific virtue, does
that make him generally
more virtuous in all things? No, just in
that
one specific area.
Likewise,
if we were to speak about
appearance or beauty,
Yusuf alaihi wasallam. If we were to
speak about patience, Ayyub alaihi
wasallam. If we were to speak about
method of revelation, we speak about
Musa alaihi wasallam. While in certain
aspects,
the prophets and messengers are not all
the same.
However, in a general sense, in a
holistic sense,
the most virtuous is Muhammad sallallahu
alaihi wasallam. After him is Ibrahim
alaihi wasallam, or we could say after
him is Ibrahim, and after Ibrahim is the
rest of the five major messengers,
right? After them are the ones mentioned
in the Quran. After them, it is the
messengers, and after them, the prophets
in general. The same thing goes with the
companions, radiyallahu anhu.
The same thing goes with the companions.
If we were to say that who is the most
virtuous companion with respect to
knowledge of halal and haram, we would
say this is Muadh ibn Jabal.
But if we were to say generally speaking
who is the most virtuous companion,
and after him, Omar. Just because Muadh
happens to be more excellent in one
aspect,
doesn't mean that he is most
the one of most virtue in general.
So, remember this. There is
general
virtue and there is specific virtue.
Right?
General virtue
means that they are generally
more virtuous than anyone else.
Specific virtue means that they are
specifically in one
or two
categories or ways happen to be more
virtuous than others, but in a general
sense they are not.
Right? This kind of understanding of
merits and this kind of understanding of
virtues is really important when we
start to get into the various virtues of
the
companions of the prophets.
Just because Abu
Abu Hurairah happens to be the most
memorized with respect to hadith
and he is the most well
versed in the hadith of the prophet sal
Allah alayhi wasallam, doesn't mean that
he is
immediately more virtuous in a general
sense.
Just like
the virtue that is held between the
prophets and messengers and the highest
ranking prophets and messengers. So, we
will continue this inshallah tomorrow
with respect to Muadh ibn Jabal and also
Abu Dharr. We'll probably split it up
into two days so that we don't confuse
them.
And then
inshallah we'll make it the
pattern that every time we come across a
narrator that we haven't mentioned
before,
we will try to
mention some of his merits, some of his
biography, and interweave it with the
rest of the prophet's biography. Nas
al Allah subhanahu an yu'allimana ma
yanfa'una wa an yanfa'ana bima allamana.
Nas'aluhu subhanahu wa ta'ala wa
an yaj'alana mimman yastami'una al qawla
[Arabic recitation]